a época número tempo rpm
em quanto tempo o alimento carneiro
é tanta fome ele carrega oportunidade de
trabalhar nos melhores restaurantes três
estrelas no guia mais importante do
mundo
a saia todo dia de casa festa da manhã e
voltar vou mandar madrugada feliz da
vida
um mês distância tecnologia inovação
menu degustação disso da silva
e eu fazia esse trajeto do restaurante
da casa onde morava 125 para em torno de
20 25 minutos
se eu pegar você estrada e quase não
tinha apóstolo eu não quero muito escuro
vai fazer muito frio era bem no interior
olá turminha bastante também e essa
tinha uma lanterninha na minha bicicleta
é nesse trajeto eu sempre pensava o meu
dia em como ele tinha sido coisas que eu
tinha aprendido e as coisas que eu tinha
errado quero várias coisas
é engraçado que no meio dessa escuridão
sempre surgem essas questões mais
existenciais
o nisso
o público proposta mega full
o rock ao mesmo tempo para o oposto
daquilo que eu tava vivendo sendo ali
ali eu entendi e aquilo era para poucos
enquanto eu queria para muito
e ali eu vi que a precificação era um
critério de exclusão e não inclusão
ah entendi que a tecnologia que eu
estava vendo e aprendendo é o nunca
seria destinada para o povo o povo que
não tinha liberdade privilégio de
escolher entende que o produtor daquele
insumo ele nunca teria dinheiro para
comprar aquela refeição
é então que acontecia era a ciência da
alimentação ela sempre estacionava na
vaga de quem podia pagar mais aquela era
a realidade era aquilo que estava sendo
planejado e desejado por muitos
sequestros
é muito muito duro reconhecer isso foi
uma mistura de envergonha o
esclarecimento ao mesmo tempo
e o pai partir disso que eu tentei
reconstruir a minha carreira na
alimentação buscando aproximar as
pessoas e o alimentos de maior poder no
alimento mais transparente
é de conhecimento alimentar para quem
quisesse quando quiser
a igreja o tempo hospital e não
significa muita coisa no centro de uma
matéria para ser comparado e a minha
matéria sempre foi alimentação ou seja
boa parte do meu tempo ele gira em torno
da alimentação e as minhas melhores
lembranças em torno de uma mesa cercada
de pessoas queridas bastante diálogo
bastante conversa muito aprendizado
e eu não conheço da minha avó falando
como se fazer um bônus anemia para você
fazer um bom rosa você precisa lavar
muito bem parabéns parabéns quando a
gente corre o gente não pode deixar nada
caindo aqui ó
é porque todos aqueles grãos o cai na
pia gente na panela toda mafalda
é uma mexeu muito comigo porque eu
comecei a entender que
a alimentação era sempre pro longo prazo
qualquer tipo de ela tinha que ser
diário
bom então seja para ganhar peso ou
perder peso intenção é
se quiser ganhar 100 gramas um paciente
com um pouquinho mais frio em uma semana
não chega lá 100 graus f401s pode ganhar
5 quilos em ordem a gente aprende com é
a pesquisa diferenciar solo dá vontade
de comer diferenciar seja a vontade de
beber homem alguém vai quando ela chega
a 515 prece galera é o mesmo tempo o
passam devagar quem não tem
o privilégio de escolha rua está comendo
comida que dar comida tem que fazer
sobrevivência
a minha fome é um jeito que o corpo
encontra prazer eu quero viver
só para quem pode escolher
o alimento alimentação gastronomia
sempre uma coisa no interior sempre
contrastes sabores explosão sensações
a alimentação quando ela é divertida ela
passa passa muito rápido
e eu entendi aqui ter tempo para
escolher essas coisas também um
privilégio vi
a linguiça porque o renis também
eu sempre defendi o ensino público
gratuito com muita garra muita dedicação
então hoje esteja na universidade os
meus negócios e busco seguir a minha
filosofia de alimentação ser justo e
acessível para poder circular sem livre
é preciso libertar-se alimentos
o youtuber me alimentar sim nós tentamos
libertar alimentação de diversas formas
maneira que a gente mais identifica é
com a fermentação fermentação de pães o
marchas dos limões as pimentas
entendimento que tá na época porque o
que tá na época ele agride menos a
sociedade como todo pensando nisso a
gente criou outras coisas a gente criou
produtos e carga esse vídeo entregamos a
preços populares entre hambúrgueres
expoente base também entregamos a preço
popular em cima outubro deu todas as
técnicas todos os nossos preparam para
as pessoas e quanto mais a gente
buscavam essa inclusão quanto mais
encher furo mas a gente cobrir aqui toda
a inclusão latinha uberaba e hoje nossa
comunidade entende essas perguntas vai
muito além do alimento
e ele é uma ideia de um mundo tendência
dumm dumm preciso informar as pessoas é
preciso educar as pessoas para que a
gente possa libertar essa alimentação
pela educação a gente entrega tudo que
compõem uma pequena parcela da soberania
alimentar através da educação a gente
entrega conhecimento conhecimento para
quem toma as decisões por nós entrega
aos poucos um pouco de possibilidade de
escolher a
o conhecimento alimentaram direito mas
também um dever de todo ser humano você
é responsável por aquilo que produz por
aquilo que você consome por aquilo que
você descarta e quando você tem essa
clareza você consegue criar e modificar
o mundo com sistema alimentar mais justo
a anemia ela já nos comprovou-se bravo
problema globais não existe uma saída
que não seja pela minha coletiva pela
educação pela ciência e pela vergonha na
cara infelizmente eu acho que a próxima
revolução alimentar ela não vai
acontecer porque
nós queremos paga por quem precisa
e nisso é porque a gente sempre acha que
vai ter tempo para solucionar as coisas
e não
o tempo ele nunca esteve a favor da
alimentação então preciso a gente fazer
as pazes com o tempo para que uma nova
revolução alimentar aconteça para quem
te entendo aqui talvez a gente esteja
colocando nossa nossos desejos acima das
nossas necessidades reais
bom e quando o alimento está livre eles
falam muito mais do que a vontade uma
necessidade de comendo
e me fala sobre discriminação e fala
sobre assédio e fala sobre
sustentabilidade políticas públicas
equidade de gênero e muito mais
e hoje a gente tenta inflammate mas sem
solucionar problemas da terra
oi gente fala inteligência artificial
mas sem acesso à educação para todos
e a gente fala em experiências
gastronômicas mas se existe soberania
alimentar tecnologia inovação muito
importante é preciso conectar mais
despedimentos da justamente por isso
para libertar alimentação que a gente
precisa desenhar o futuro e sirva para
todos
e para que essa sombra do tempo ela
nunca mais seja fome
um homem de comer a forma de saber e a
forma de viver
é muito obrigado